bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public on est
ensemble pendant 910 minutes comme tous
les jours à 18h et 22h sur Public Sénat
vous le savez la promesse elle est dans
le titre de l'émission donner du sens à
l'actualité se mettre au service du
public vous proposer des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 18
janvier
678000 naissances en 2023 le nombre le
plus faible depuis 19 946 le constat est
inquiétant les conséquences économiques
réelles mais doit-on pour autant
convoquer un réarmement démographique
comme l'a proposé Emmanuel Macron mardi
soir plusieurs associations féministes
et Parti de Gauche critique le retour
d'une politique nataliste d'autres
réclam des mesures à la hauteur du défi
on en débat dans une minute et puis pour
notre second thème volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour cette question à
quoi servent l'ONU et son secrétaire
général
j'ai vu de nombreux désastres
humanitaires dans le monde mais je n'ai
jamais vu de carnage climatique de cette
ampleur les pays riches ont la
responsabilité morale d'aider les pays
en développement comme le Pakistan à se
remettre de telle catastrophe et à
s'adapter parce que malheureusement
elles se répèteront à
l'avenir Antonio gouterz voie forte pour
alerter sur l'urgence climatique
beaucoup plus discret quand il s'agit de
dénoncer agression russe en Ukraine ou
de s'engager sur le conflit Hamas Israël
les Nations Unies sont critiqués peut-on
réformer cette organisation notamment
son Conseil de sécurité faut-il créer
une autre instance internationale mieux
adapté au nouvel ordre mondiale ne ratez
pas la confrontation de nos experts dans
trois qu4 d'heure mais d'abord donc ce
chiffre historiquement bas de la
natalité dans notre pays c'est Hugo
lemogier qui dresse l'état des lieux
nouvelle formule du président de la
République
le réarmement
démographique une réponse selon lui à
l'annonce d'un recul historique de la
fécondité par l'INC moins de 700000
bébés en
2023 résultat le solde naturel qui
mesure la différence entre le nombre de
morts et de naissance est au plus bas
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale le
solde
naturel pourrait devenir
négatif à partir du milieu des années
2030 et un petit peu avant vers 2000 27
si l'indicateur conjoncturel de
fécondité se situait à 1,6 enfants par
femme en cause notamment l'allongement
des étude et la précarisation des jeunes
sur le marché du travail des phénomènes
qui ont bouleversé l'équilibre entre vie
de famille et vie professionnelle on se
sent prêt avoir par exemple une
responsabilité parentale plutôt à on est
à 29 on va aller vers 30 sûrement alors
que dans les années 70 on était plutôt à
22 21 c'est des Chang changement de
calendrier considérable c'est pas un
refus de l'enfant mais c'est les
conséquences d'une certaine façon
de d'une d'une charge plus grande
aujourd'hui pour s'occuper de l'enfant
cette charge et par ailleurs inégalement
répartie dans le couple les femmes
payant le plus lourd tribut le Défenseur
des droits explique qu'un tiers des
femme va être discriminée dans son
travail en raison de la grossesse ou de
la maternité que 36 % des femmes vont
réduire leur activité professionnelle à
partir du deuxè enfant alors que
seulement 9 % des hommes que
lorsqu'elles sont séparées parce que ça
arrive dans 50 % des cas quasiment et
bien les responsabilités paternelles
aussi c'est de ne pas payer sa pension
alimentaire quand elle reste en couple
le partage des tâches ménagères enfin
tout ça va sûrement aussi peser sur le
fait que les conditions d'accueil de de
TR quatre enfants ne sont absolument pas
réunis pour que ce choix puisse être
fait une situation d'autant plus
difficile qu'il manque des déjà 230000
places en crèche le gouvernement s'est
engagé à en créer 100000 d'ici 2017 le
double d'ici
2030 la natalité nouvelle obsession
politique on en débat tout de suite avec
Gérard François Dumont bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes professeur àas Sorbonne
président de la revue Population et
avenir dont le dernier numéro s'intitule
politique familiale et vitalité
démograique vous êtes économiste et
géographe Céline pic bonsoir bienvenue à
vous aussi porte-parole d' le féminisme
j'accueille Pascal Perino bonsoir et
bienvenue Pascal vous êtes politologue
professeur à sciencesp Paris Etam Trani
bonsoir dans le rôle de l'éditorialiste
politique ce soir dans dans sens public
on les a vu mais je rappelle quand même
ces ces derniers chiffre de l'INC pour
pour commencer
678000 naissances l'an dernier 6,6 % sur
1 an plus faible au nombre depuis 46 et
puis le taux de fécondité également
regardons ce ce ce chiffre 1,68 enfants
par femme l'an dernier et c'était
1,79 en 2022 Gérard François Dumont à
quel point ces chiffres sont inquiétants
faut-il employer ce terme d'ailleurs
alors ces chiffres sont le résultat de
politique publique qui ont fait diminuer
la liberté de choix des des femmes et
des familles en matière d'enfants et
donc il devait arriver moi je les avais
annoncé dès 2014 dès qu'on a remis en
cause les éléments fondamentaux de la
politique familiale ils ont
inévitablement des conséquences alors la
première à laquelle on pense toujours
c'est la conséquence économique
consistant à se dire les nouveaux nés
d'aujourd'hui c'est eux qui vont
façonner la population active dans 20 25
ans et donc on risque d'avoir moins
d'actifs donc moins de possibilités de
création de richesse et donc des
difficultés à financer notre protection
sociale mais en réalité l'évolution des
nouveaux-nés a des effets immédiats
immédiats parce que une famille qui a
attend un enfant ou un enfant
supplémentaire elle va se mobiliser pour
accueillir cet
enfant elle va modifier sa structure de
consommation donc par exemple au lieu
d'aller en vacances au Maldives ou
ailleurs elle va peut-être devoir
investir sont rares les moy voà bien sûr
oh maintenant il y a des tarifs très B
c'est vrai vous avez raison mais ça
c'est un autre débat écologique un vrai
débat écologique vous avez raison voilà
et et puis surtout elle va peut-être
aussi faire des efforts professionnels
pour améliorer ses revenus
professionnels
h c'est vrai ai au niau des
commesou Absolum fondamental puisque
effectivement une commune en fonction de
l'évolution de sa population jeune elle
va plus ou moins être stimulée à
investir dans l'offre scolaire dans
l'offre culturelle dans l'offre sportive
vous parlez des politiques publiques
c'est une P face à ce constat que peut
faire que doit faire un état alors
beaucoup de choses qui n'ont pas été
annoncées d'ailleurs dans le discours de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui sont par contre à
l'agenda des féministes depuis très
longtemps premièrement on a on observe
quandême une fermeture des maternités
euh ça c'est quelque chose sur lequel on
se bat sur le fait que aujourd'hui des
femmes doivent faire 1h 1h30 de voiture
pour aller accoucher on a également des
problématiques de mode de garde euh on
réclame les féministes réclamament
depuis maintenant longtemps des
décennies je dirais maintenant un
service public de la petite enfance
c'est-à-dire à une possibilité d'accueil
en crèche qui soit beaucoup plus
importante et qui soit financé par
l'État au même titre que les l'école
aujourd'hui et ça c'est absolument
indispensable puisque je rappelle que la
crèche c'est aussi une tarification
progressive qui permet à toutes les
femmes puisque je pense qu'on parlera du
congé parental et de la modification qui
a été faite et proposé d'une réduction
du congé parental aujourd'hui quand vous
êtes au SMIC en particulier vous n'avez
pas la possibilité il n'est pas
intéressant pour vous de faire appel à
une nounou ou à une autre mode de garde
qui est basé sur le crédit d'impôt je
vais rentrer un petit peu dans dans les
détails mais le crédit d'impôt c'est
pour ceux qui payent des impôts voilà
tout simplement donc il y a toute une
partie de la population partie de la
population en particulier pour les
femmes à bas salaire pour laquelle une
solution collective de mode de garde de
crèche et absolument indispensable pour
ne pas être éloigné de l'emploi je peux
continuerendra plus tard encore plein
plein de questions sur sur les
conséquences et sur ce que pourrait être
une une politique publique et on
reviendra je vous donnerai la parole
évidemment pour évaluer un peu le les et
notamment les mots employés par Emmanuel
Macron hier soir Pascal Perin votre
votre avis général peut-être sur le le
constat JEE sur ce ce constat qu'est-ce
que ça dit d'un pays et en quoi pour
vous c'est inquiétant éventuellement non
non c'est c'est préoccupant parce que le
6,6 en une seule année de décroissance
c'est énorme quand vous prenez les
séries d'évolution d'une année à l'autre
d'habitude ça tournait autour de 2 à 3 %
et même pendant de nombreuses années
c'était moins 2 % d'une année à l'autre
l'ut là on passe à
6,6 donc ça veut dire qu'il y a un point
d'infléchissement une chute qui doit
interroger en effet sur l'état de la
société des éléments économiques sociaux
de politiques familiales ont été portés
je crois qu'il faudrait peut-être y
ajouter pour le débat des éléments
culturels euh c'est-à-dire qu'on
s'aperçoit dans de nombreuses sociétés
pas simplement la société française de
pays développés qu'il y a un changement
d'attitude par rapport à l'avenir je le
vois par exemple dans quelque chose de
très simple on a fait une enquête
exhaustive sur les étudiants et les
étudiantes de sciencesp la conception
qu'ils ont de l'avenir est de plus en
plus catastrophique c'est lié notamment
au à l'urgenceque bien sûr bien sûr il y
a une un catastrophisme une anxiété
écologique qui produit on le voit chez
certaines femmes l'idée que c'est pas la
peine d'avoir un enfant dans un monde
qu'elle conçoiv comme étant profondément
dégradé à l'horizon de de de 10 20 ans
et puis il y a aussi euh quelque chose
qui continue à faire son œuvre
c'est-à-dire la légitime le
légitime besoin légitime envie
d'émancipation individuelle au travers
en particulier du travail pour les
femmes même si les femmes françaises
travaillent beaucoup he le taux
d'activité des femmes en France est
extrêmement élevé euh il n'atteint pas
celui des hommes mais il est extrêmement
extrêmement élevé et on s'aperç soit
qu'il y a je le vois un peu comme aux
États-Unis puisque j'enseigne également
aux États-Unis chez certaines femmes
l'idée que c'est le mouvement qu'elles
appellent child free hein libre
d'enfants c'est-à-dire que il y a un
choix pas vouloir revendiquer comme tel
en effet de ne pas faire d'enfants avec
même parfois une
valorisation du fait que une vie
accomplie ça se fait sans enfants hein
et ça c'est quelque chose culturellement
d'assez d'assz nouveau et tout ça toutes
ces causes que vous les rajouté les unes
aux autres et bien ça se traduit en
effet par un affaissement de la natalité
ce mouvement child Free c'est une pque
c'est pas forcément inquiétant oui c'est
pour ça que je voulais questionner moi
le mot inquiétant en fait et
volontairement je je utilisé savis ça le
mot inquiétant moi me me dérange un
petit peu puisque je fais quand même la
distinction entre deux choses entre une
politique familiale et donc
effectivement quelles sont les
conditions qui sont offertes aux femmes
pour accueillir un enfant est-ce
qu'elles sont bonnes et qu'est-ce que
est-ce que le désir d'enfant peut être
satisfait par rapport à l'environnement
et ça a été dit économique et puis une
politique nataliste où on prendrait
comme objectif que les femmes doivent
avoir des enfants pour la grandeur de la
nation et je pense que cette
revendication c'est aussi une
revendication des féministe d'avoir
réellement le choix et d'avoir un désir
d'enfant ou pas et aujourd'hui je pense
que avec l'émancipation des femmes cette
affirmation de dire je ne veux pas
d'enfant est davantage entendu mais il
faudrait le réincr écrire dans un
mouvement féministe plus large qui qui
est une constante et je vous ai amené je
vous fais une petite citation puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de l'avortement et de la
constitutionnalisation à venir du droit
à l'avortement j'ai je vous ai emmené le
Manifeste des 343 donc le fameux
manifeste écrit par Simon de beauauvoir
il y a maintenant plus de 50 ans publié
par Le Nouvel Observateur s'appait comme
ça à l'époque le nouvel le Nouvel
Observateur en
1971 qui explique pourquoi il faut le
droit à l'avortement ouis et ce n'est
pas uniquement un problème de santé
publique c'est une question aussi de
réappropriation de nos corps les corps
des femmes qui ne répondent pas à une
politique nataliste et je vous cite
juste une phrase allez-y sur la lutte
pour le droit à l'IVG c'est un combat
enthousiasment dans la mesure où si je
le gagne je commence seulement à
m'appartenir en propre et non plus à
l'état une étape pour parvenir au
contrôle complet de la production des
enfants je ferai un enfant si j'en ai
envie nulle pression morale nulle
institution nul impératif économique ne
peut m'y contraindre cela est mon
pouvoir politique dernière phrase je
ferai un enfant si j'en ai envie et si
la société dans laquelle je le fais
naître est convenable pour moi si elle
ne fait pas de moi l'esclave de cet
enfant sa bonne sa tête de turc signé
Simone de Beauvoir et donc il y a
effectivement cet enjeu aussi de ne pas
répondre à une politique nataliste
dirigée par l'État et je pense que c'est
ça qui a fait un petit peu bondir les
féministes avec terme
démographique oui avec le terme
réarmement démographique notamment on y
reviendra nous dira ce qu'elle en pense
dans un instant je fais la distinction
donc entre politique nataliste et
polique est-ce que vous faites aussi
cette distinction ben elle est
absolument fondamentale une politique
nataliste n'a aucun intérêt pourquoi
parce qu'elle va simplement s'intéresser
au nombre des naissances c'est pas ce
dont on a besoin ce dont on a besoin
c'est d'une politique familiale qui
donne la liberté de choix or aujourd'hui
cette liberté de choix elle n'existe pas
prenons un exemple vous venez de de
citer le fait que l'on veut mettre dans
la Constitution le droit à l'avortement
je dirais pourquoi pas mais à ce
moment-là faut mettre aussi le droit de
choisir un d'accueillir un enfant si les
gens le souhaitent la liberté elle doit
être totale on est dans un système dire
d'accueillir d'adopter non une politique
à ce moment-là faut faut dire oui oui
chaque femme et chaque couple doit avoir
la liberté de ne pas accueillir
d'enfants s'il le souhait don moy à av
d'en avoir c'est ça or ce n'est pas le
cas parce que Pascal Perino a très bien
résumer les différents éléments mais si
je regarde la situation de la France
toutes ces dernières décennies en fait
la fécondité n'a pas évolué de façon
régulière nous avons une su on était
même pardon de vous interrompre moi
enfin ce que j'ai retenu c'est que la
France était un cas particulier en
europeou était elle était elle était
elle était elle était en viier et elle
était en viier donc mais si vous
regardez si vous voulez depuis toutes
ces dernières décennies l'évolution de
la fécondité elle a connu des périodes
de Haus et des périodes de baisse et à
chaque fois vous constatez que c'est la
suite de décisions politique négative ou
positive de politique FAM donneznous un
exemple qu'est-ce qui fait que la France
qui était un un qui était envié comme
vous le dites dans d'autres pays
d'Europe finalement rentre dans une
espèce de norme qu'est-ce qui manque
aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé très
simplement c'est qu'en 2014 on a remis
en cause les fondements de la politique
familiale tels qu'ils avaient été
élaborés plusieurs décennies avant et
qui était transpolitique je rappelle par
exemple le ccient familial a été voté à
l'unanimité du Parlement je rappelle
Queen
1998 quand Lionel Jospin Premier
ministre a voulu remettre en cause
l'université l'universalité des
allocations familiales qui s'est plaint
c'est le parti communiste qui a dit mais
on remet en cause un élément central de
la société française et Lionel Jospin
n'a pu mettre en place sa mesure de
suppression de l'universalité qu'une
durée symbolique 9 mois hein
c'est-à-dire c'était vraiment une
politique transpolitique or en 2014 j'ai
pas répondu à votre question et bien on
a on a mis à bas ces principes donc
réforme du j'ai une question c'est
pourquoi 2014 2024 C il y a quand même
une dizaine d'années la remise vous
estimez que ça mis 10 2014 j'ai annoncé
la baisse je vous signale que les
mesures annoncées en 2014 ont été mises
en place en 2015 et la baisse elle a
commencé en 2016 c'est aussi rapide que
ça et oui oui le 6,6 % de cette année
par rapport à l'année pr vous le liez
encore qu'en fait nous avons une
population qui a perdu confiance en la
politique familiale parce qu' il faut
pas oublier qu'il y a trois éléments
ouais alors je vous interromp parce que
si vous partez dans trois éléments ça va
être trop long et on a encore beaucoup
de temps de débat et beaucoup d'éléments
à voir et je voudrais quand même qu'on
rentre un peu dans le détail de ce qu'a
annoncé le président de la République
parce que c'est ce qui justifie notre
débat ce soir donc il fait de la la
hausse des naissances un des objectifs
prioritaire de son second quinena alors
avec notamment ce nouveau congé de
naissance on l'écoute
après l'allongement du congé paternité
je crois profondément que la mise en
place d'un nouveau congé de naissance
sera un élément utile dans une une telle
stratégie congé de naissance qui viendra
remplacer le congé parental actuel
d'abord il sera mieux rémunéré il
permettra au deux parents d'être auprès
de leur enfant pendant 6 mois s'ils le
souhaitent mais surtout il sera plus
court que le congé parental actuel qui
peut parfois aller jusqu'à 3 ans et qui
éloigne beaucoup de femmes du marché du
travail mais qui aussi crée beaucoup
d'angoisse parce qu' il est extrêmement
peu et mal rémunéré et donc créer des
situations parfois impossibles Pascal
Perino comment vous évaluez comment vous
jugez cette proposition est-ce que pour
vous elle va dans le bon sens j'ai
l'impression mais je ne suis pas un
spécialiste de la politique
démographique mais j'ai l'impression que
ça va plutôt dans le bon sens dans la
mesure où en effet on voyait bien que
l'ancien congé parental avait
l'inconvénient pour la population
féminine de l'éloigner extrêmement
longtemps de l'emploi et ensuite le
retour à l'emploi était quelque chose de
difficile hein il y avait une forme de
marginalisation à l'issue du congé
parental le congé qui est prévu le congé
dit de naissance on verra exactement
quelles en sont ces ces modalités aurait
l'intérêt de rassembler davantage le le
père et la mère dans une période
relativement courte de 6 mois avec une
indemnité qui serait une indemnité plus
importante et non pas une indemnité
voilà qui ne change pas profondément les
choses la condition
socioéconomique du ménage mais moi il y
a quelque chose si vousz vu de
l'extérieur aussi qui me surprend le
taux de natalité il chute beaucoup dans
toutes les catégories he je regardais ça
avant de venir dans toutes les
catégories mais là où le taux de
natalité reste le plus fort c'est en
haut de l'échelle sociale et en bas de
l'échelle socialein là où ça s'effondre
c'estàdire il faut pas croire que tout
est lié au social et à l'économique hein
il y a aussi des facteurs qui sont des
facteurs haut des facteurs culturels où
en bas de l'échelle sociale on peut
valoriser encore la famille nombreuse
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire aujourd'hui
une famille nombreuse alors que dans les
couches moyennes la crise que l'on
décrivait tout à l'heure est beaucoup
plus vive hein et que en haut de
l'échelle sociale et bien on a en effet
une aisance qui vous permet d'accomplir
est-ce que vous le liez au sentiment de
déclassement d'une partie des classes
moyennes en France par exemple peut-être
oui certainement certainement et c'est
lié à ce que je disais tout à l'heure
aussi sur la conception même de l'avenir
quand vous êtes dans une société dans
lequelle vous avez l'impression que les
générations à venir vont se porter de
moins en moins bien qu'elles seront
déclassées que vous-même vous commencez
à connaître un déclassement au travers
de vous-même ou au travers de votre
époux de votre épouse c'est ce ne sont
pas les conditions idéales pour faire
des enfants c'estine pic sur la
proposition d'Emmanuel Macron voilà
proposition précise d'une certaine façon
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous n avez
dit tout à l'heure attention parce qu'il
y a une il y a effectivement une
réduction du du du congé maternité si on
si on comprend bien ce que nous dit le
chef de l'État ah non parental du congé
parental congé parental congé parental
le congé parental alors première
inquiétude c'est qu'on n pas encore le
montant aujourd'hui qui va remplacer les
430 € à titre de comparaison en Suède
par exemple on est à plus de 80 % du
salaire donc c'est vraiment au
comparable à ce qu'on a aujourd'hui avec
des taux de
remplacement du congé maternité
extrêmement élevé on va voir si on va
avoir 800 1000 ou un pourcentage du
salaire deuxièmement on va se à quelque
chose de très clair c'est une justement
pour les les femmes avec des bas
salaires l'impossibilité de faire garder
le leurs enfants jusqu'à l'entrée en
maternelle parce que la raison pour
laquelle aujourd'hui les femmes poussent
le congé parental jusqu'à 3 ans c'est
qu'elles n'ont pas de de possibilité de
garde de solution de garde qui soi
accessible et qu'elle ne passe pas
l'intégralité r marginalisation pardon
nous interrompe le risque de
marginalisation don don dont nous parle
Pascal la précarité et la
marginalisation elle existe déjà pour
les femmes à bas salaire ce sont des
femmes qui ont par exemple des des des
des horaires décalés ce sont les femmes
qui sont aujourd'hui caissières femmes
de ménage et cetera celles-là si on ne
leur offre pas des places en crèche
elles n'ont pas la possibilité de faire
garder leurs enfants avec le SMIC
puisque finalement tout ce qu'elles vont
gagner en salaire elles vont le perdre
en fris de garde et donc là on va
aujourd'hui on bricole et ces femmes
elles bricolent en particulier avec les
grands-mères et on ne résout pas les
problématiques de mode de garde pour les
bas salaires qui vont se poser
inévitablement avec cette réduction il
il faut absolument avec cette réduction
accompagner une montée en puissance de
du nombre de places en crèche qui est
quelque chose d'absolument essentiel
c'est une politique globale c'est ce que
je comprends la politique globale
j'avais peut-être un mini tacot tac par
rapport à ce qui est dit sur les classes
moyennes je trouve ça très intéressant
d'analyser quand même la politique
familiale aujourd'hui c'est que d'un
côté on a les allocations familiales qui
sont aujourd'hui sous conditions de
ressources et donc passer à un certain
moment elles sont dégressives qui qui
donc qui bénéficient essentiellement
plutôt au bas ou au moyen salaire et de
l'autre côté on a le cocient familial
qui je le rappelle bénéficie énormément
plus de 80 % au 20 % les plus aisés en
France c'est le cotient familial est
quelque chose de profondément
inégalitaire et qui coûte aujourd'hui 19
milliards au aux finances de l'État et
donc qui profite au 20 % les deux
premiers déciles des revenus et donc je
pense que les classes moyennes sont
aussi un ventreemou de la politique
familiale en France du fait de ces deux
polarisations allocation familiale pour
les bas revenus et cocient familiale
pour les haut revenus alors Gérard
François lumont je vous allez pouvoir
terminer ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure sur 2014 et le et le virage si
vous voulez bien je vais vous mais
d'abord je propose un autre une un autre
un autre chiffre tiens à nos
téléspectateurs euh c'est le résultat
d'une étude cantar publiée l'an dernier
sur le désir exprimé d'enfants des
Français c'est intéressant près de 2,3
enfants par femme
2,27 euh je vous repose la question
comment permettre à ces couples
d'assouvir leur désir d'enfant qu'est-ce
qui manque à la politique familiale
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui manque en fait
il y a TR changé qu'est de quoi a besoin
une famille quand elle atteend un enfant
ou un enfant supplémentaire elle a trois
problèmes premier problème est-ce que la
venue de cet enfant va ne va pas trop
baisser mon pouvoir d'achat ou or
effectivement toutes les réformes qui
ont été faites y compris celle du cent
familiale parce que là c'est mon
désaccord avec Madame parce qu'il
faudrait lire relire la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme de 1789 qui dit bien
que les familles doivent être imposé en
fonction de leur capacité contributive
orors effectivement une famille mettons
de cadre bah selon qu'elle élève trois
enfants ou qu' élève zéro sa capacité
contributive n'est pas la même donc donc
si vous voulez le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui des familles quand elles ont
un enfant supplémentaire a
considérablement baissé entre cette fin
de l'universalité la la réforme du congé
parental et cetera deuxième élément
fondamental c'est est-ce que je vais
pouvoir concilier vie professionnelle VI
familial à cet égard il faut rappeler un
élément fondamental c'est que l'État a
diminué les dotations collectivité
territorial et aux communes et surtout
que les communes n'ont plus de
lisibilité sur leur recettes à 1 an à 2
ans et encore moins à 3 ans mais même à
un an ell n'ont plus de visisibilité
donc en fait les communes même si les
maires ne le crient pas sous les toits
elles ont considérablement diminuer les
investissements en crèche comme en
relais assistante maternelle d'ailleurs
et il y a même un rapport officiel qui
explique que le nombre de crèches
réalisé n'a été que 16 % par rapport à
ce qui avait été prévu donc vous voyez
qu'entre la réforme du congé parental
plus ses dotations et le troisième
élément bien entendu c'est le problème
du logement parce que voilà il faut
pouvoir se loger or nous avons eu tout
un ensemble de réglementations
maltusiennes qui font qu'aujourd'hui les
mis en chantier de logement ont
considérablement diminué et nous avons
malheureusement un certain nombre de
lois qui sont négatives en la matière y
compris d'ailleurs la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation qu'il faut rappeler
d'ailleurs queelle n'a absolument pas
profité aux familles puisquen fait ce
sont uniquement les personnes qui
étaient très aisées qui n'avaient pas
d'enfants qu'en on bénéficiit le plus
puisque je vous rappelle qu'il y avait
des abattements pour charge de famille
en la matière ouais alors ce mot cette
expression réarmement démographique on
va en parler ensemble et je vous propose
pour commencer d'écouter le président de
la République c'est quand il nous parle
d'infertilité la natalité baisse aussi
parce que l'infertilité progresse et je
parle là d'une forme de tabou du siècle
mais les Meur se changent on fait les
enfants de plus en plus tard
l'infertilité masculine comme féminine a
beaucoup progressé ces dernières années
et fait souffrir beaucoup de couples un
grand plan de lutte contre ce fléo sera
engagé pour permettre justement ce
réarmement démographique TER traduit
cette expression réarmement
démographique ça vous a fait comment
dire sursaauter oui nous sommes en
guerre hein comme dirait l'autre alors
on nous avait annoncé pour mardi le
réarmement civique le réarmement
économique et voilà qu' au milieu des
ores de la salle desfêes et bien
Emmanuel Macron nous sort donc le
réarmement démographique de son chapeau
immédiatement comme de nombreuses
personnes l'expression m'interpelle je
donne un coup de coude à mon voisin
façon e eh tu as entendu déjà parce que
et ben ce mélange de vocabulaire le
vocabulaire guerrier de l'univers
martial et le sujet des bébés et bien
j'avoue que je n'étais pas du tout prête
on est passé du fête l'amour pas la
guerre à fête l'amour et la guerre comme
si nos enfants étaient donc de bons
petits soldats enrôlés dans la future
grande guerre guerre économique mais
guerre quand même Emmanuel Macron a
ressuscité donc en plus une image d'ENT
temp avec cette expression une image
d'un temp qu'en plus on n pas du tout
envie de revoir celle de l'entre de
guerre lorsque la France avait les yeux
braqués sur la démographie allemande
dans la préparation d'un nouveau conflit
mondial alors qu'en plus aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas du tout de lien clair entre
démographie et puissance comme le montre
et bien le cas de l'Allemagne plus
puissante économiquement que nous et qui
fait moins d'enfants que nous est-ce que
c'est la seule maladresse que vous voyez
dans cette expression bah la deuxème
c'est que quand vous avez quand vous
faites un enfant est-ce que vous avez
vraiment envie de penser à Emmanuel
Macron bah certains ou certaines
peut-être hein mais voilà pas sûr qu'on
a envie de répondre à cette question non
je rentrerai pas à ce pointlà dans votre
intimité mais parce que cela ne me
regarde pas et c'est ça le deuxième
problème c'est que cela ne le regarde
pas mélanger comme ça la sphère intime
votre projet de vie le plus personnel
avec la grandeur de la France et bien ça
colle pas du tout avec ce que l'on pense
aujourd'hui c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
la gauche et les féministes ont
notamment pensé immédiatement à la
servante écarlate cette dystopie de
Margaret Atwood où les rares femmes qui
peuvent encore avoir des enfants sont
entièrement dédiées à la procréation
donc une vision assez cauchemardeste ok
vous forcez peut-être un peu le TR il a
quand même parlé d'un sujet qui peut
susciter des inquiétudes légitimes
Emmanuel Macron c'est pas un sujet tabou
la de la natalité c'est pour ça qu'on en
a débattu déjà pendant une quinzaine de
minutes mais voilà avec cette punchline
et si peu de précision derrière on vient
de le dire un congé naissance plus court
mieux rémunéré c'est pas difficile de
faire mieux que les 430 € qu'il y a donc
aujourd'hui par mois pour le congé
parental mais si c'est pas
substantiellement plus important on peut
penser que ça changera absolument rien
sinon il a aussi parlé d'un plan sur
l'infertilité très bien ça fait 2 ans
déjà qu'un rapport de 140 pages est sur
la table du gouvernement et attend de
voir enfin les préconisations mises en
place d'ailleurs voilà ce qu'a dit le
co-auteur de ce rapport le professeur
Samir Amama qui est aussi le président
de la Fédération Française de l'étude de
la reproduction voilà ce qui répond à
Libération il ne faut surtout pas
paraître pronataliste mais informé et
éduqué sans culpabiliser ni moraliser il
ne s'agit pas d'obliger tout le monde à
faire des enfants bref tout ça c'est ce
qu'on a expliqué c'est un sujet
multifactorial c'est un sujet de santé
publique il faut agir sur les modes de
garde l'articulation entre vie
professionnelle vie privée agir vous
l'avez dit sur l'éch anxiété donner des
perspectives et surtout laisser
tranquille ceux qui ne veulent pas
d'enfant sinon imaginez cette dystopie
Thomas alors qu'Emmanuel Macron confirme
donc un virage à droite les militants de
gauche arrêtent de faire des enfants par
pur esprit de contradiction mais vous
imaginez l'engorgement des écoles
privées merci beaucoup euh devient un
peu sérieux c'est linepque ce champ
lexical vous aussi vous a fait tiqué
pourquoi ce champ lexical il il
réétablit justement cette politique
nataliste dont on parlait au départ de
cette conversation et et la politique
natthalis de dire que les femmes sont
aujourd'hui au service de l'État pour
garantir une croissance démographique
censée apporter de la croissance et
cetera nous ne sommes pas le projet
industriel d'Emmanuel Macron je le
répète et vraiment la question et la
seule question c'est est-ce que le désir
d'enfant qui effectivement à 2, 23 peut
être satisfait dans des bonnes
conditions mais la façon dont nous
décidons si nous voulons des enfants ou
pas ne concerne pas Emmanuel Macron et
c'est très inquiétant et je trouve que
ça donne des des des gages des gages à
l'extrême droite h puis je rappeller
quand même que quand on parle de
démographie hein le sold démographique
c'est la somme de deux choses c'est la
c'est la somme du sold de naturel donc
l'écart entre naissance et décès et le
solde migratoire et là-dessus alors
qu'on vient de sortir d'une séquence sur
la loi immigration où on avait pas
l'impression que le problème
démographique était un problème au
contraire on voit bien que derrière on a
quand même une rhtorique qui est pas
très loin à l'extrême droite sur la
l'histoire du Grand remplacement et que
cette focal
sur une politique nataliste c'est avant
tout qu'on fasse des
Français face à à la vague
migratoire très dangereuse dans ce que
elle peut cacher d'accord on y reviendra
lien immigration effectivement et et
démographie dans dans un court instant
ce sera notre dernier chapitre on va
vraiment y consacrer du temps mais y a
une question vous poser je vous la poser
peut-être à tous les deux avec vous
d'abord Pascal
Perino j'entends votre argument sur
l'intimité et cetera mais est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce qu'on peut faire autrement
vous voyez ce que je veux dire parce qu'
le périno quant on parle de natalité de
politique familiale on parle forcément
de l'intimité d'un couple et de
l'intimité des Français oui ou non oui
bien sûr bien sûr parce qu'à la fin des
fins en effet ça se traduit dans des
comportements qui relèvent de l'intime
hein voilà et la politique familiale
cherche à faire évoluer ces
comportements qui sont des comportements
privés disons voilà hein et le
franchissement de la barrière privé
public par le politique est de plus en
plus fréquent hein et de plus en plus
fréquent c'est une espèce de de de l'âme
de de l'âme de fond mais quand on écoute
le président tout de même il parlait de
fertilité oui hein et c'est vrai là tout
à l'heure on parlait à juste titre du
corps des femmes et de la nécessaire
souveraineté des femmes sur leur corps
dans l'acte d'avorter ou de ne pas
avorter mais parlons du corps des hommes
moi je lisais de multiples enquêtes dans
lequel on voit par exemple la qualité
des spermatozoïdes pour la reproduction
chuter drastiquement et beaucoup de
médecins vous le disent donc il y a des
effets aussi de la apparemment d'après
ce que l'on sait de la pollution sur la
qualité des gamettes qui est un élément
là on est dans le biologique voyez on
est
parti sur l'infertilités ont proposé par
exemple de d'agir et bien sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens d'avoir des
avertissements voilà ex bon et là c'est
un problème qui doit être qui doit être
analysé hein et qui demande certainement
des une repost mais une reposte de
longue haline parce que c'est pas du
jour au lendemain que l'on pourra agir
sur ce type de variable mais on voit
bien que ces comportements intimes
auxquels vous faites allusion on a
l'impression d'être dans le tout petit
du privé et bien en fait ça répond à des
sollicitations qui viennent de partout
quoi Gérard François Dumond est-ce que
on peut faire une politique familiale
politiquement neutre vous voyez ce que
je veux dire mais bien sûr c'est une
politique
de c'est une politique de liberté de
choix en revanche qui est important de
comprendre et là en tant que démographe
c'est que le privé c'est du collectif
parce qu'en fait la somme des
comportements individuels engendre des
comportements collectifs on le voit très
bien par exemple en matière de de de de
mariage et en matière de naissance hor
mariage il y a à une époque on était
dans une société qui n'acceptait pas les
naissances hor mariage certaines années
on a eu jusque le tiers des mariages qui
étaient des mariages de femmes qui
étaient déjà enceintes de leur enfant au
moment du mariage parce que la société
considérait qu'il fallait courir aller
voir le maire bon cette société a changé
et aujourd'hui bah les naissances au
mariages sont accepté comme les autres
plus d'ailleurs donc on croit si vous
voulez c'est vrai que le le couple qui
décide de se marier ou de ne pas se
marier la femme qui décide ou non
d'avoir un enfant effectivement c'est un
comportement individuel mais quand vous
aditionnez tout ceci ça dans des
logiques collectives et c'est pour ça
que la science démographique existe elle
n'existerait pas alors c'est plus
compréhensible à travers la mortalité
c'estd si vous regardez les gens qui
auprès de vous sont morts l'année
l'année dernière bah vous allez voir un
centenaire vous allez voir un jeune qui
a eu un accident de voiture vous allez
voir un quelqu'un qui a une crise
cardiaque à 44 ans et cetera et vous
allez vous dire tout ça sont les destins
individuels mais quand vous additionnez
ces destin individuel ils entrent dans
des logiques collectives cine P est-ce
que c'est pas quand même rapidement en
le sujet c'est pas que la puissance
publique se Mle de l'intime le problème
c'est l'injonction vraiment c'est là
vraiment que je trouve qu'il y a la
terminologie c'est l'injonction problème
sinon que les
comportements je reviens aux
conséquences économiques et sociales de
la baisse de c'est quand même une forme
d'appauvrissement d'un pays est-ce que
vous est-ce que vous acceptez cet
argument ou pas
euh mais on peut pas imaginer
aujourd'hui de demander aux femmes le MO
injonction il a été donné de faire des
enfants pour la grandeur de la nation
donc il y a unû mais c'est normal que
les politiques s'en emparent parce que
c'est c'est quand même un risque
d'appauvrissement P je je répète le
début de mon propos les politiques ont
un parce que le privé est politique moi
je pense en tant que féministe que le
privé politique mais le politique doit
s'assurer que les femmes qui ont un
désir d'enfant puissent le faire dans
des bonnes conditions et qu'il n'y ait
pas de différence entre le chiffre de la
fécondité qui est aujourd'hui à 1,7 et
le désir d'enfant qui est à 2,2
mais n pas Nants en absolu qui nous
intéresse aujourdhui si les femmes ont
décidé de vouloir 1,5 enfants bah elles
veulent 1,5 enfants ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui donc c'est la question du
désir d'enfant j'aimerais bien savoir
comment ce chiffre de 2,23 d'ailleurs
est
calculé en tout cas c'est de satisfaire
le désir d'enfant des femmes sur lequel
on ne doit pas intervenir puisque c'est
quelque chose qui est profondément
l'État par les décisions qu' prend
influence les comportements privés en
permanence par sa
politiqueresite nous dernière chose pour
aller quand même dans le sens aussi sur
le fait que il y a des normes
culturelles il faut regarder un petit
peu ce qui se passe aussi en Allemagne
en Allemagne il a un taux de féc un taux
de fécondité extrêmement bas depuis très
longtemps et on voit surtout un chiffre
qu'on m'avait donné il y a 3 4 ans je
sais pas s'il est toujours le c'était
une femme sur deux qui avait un bac + 5
décidé de ne pas avoir d'enfants
exactement comme Angela Merkel les FEM
qui veulent conilier vie profession Lam
finir c'est ce que j'allais dire voilà
et donc effectivement il est très mal vu
de reprendre le travail après quelques
mois seulement et la cons voilà la la la
désignation des Maes corbeau c'est
vraiment très mal vu c'est vraiment la
norme culturelle qui pèse sur les femmes
et il faut choisir et en France on avait
réussi à essayer de de favoriser cette
conciliation et c'est ça qui devrait
être l'objectif des politiques publiques
la conciliation VI privée vie parentale
merci 7 minutes pour parler du lien
entre natalité et immigration je propose
à audre vetas de nous rejoindre bonsoir
Audrey avec donc ce rapport de l'INS
cette hiver démographique on peut
employer cette cette expression on
entend on lit de plus en plus cette
affirmation notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux 40 % des enfants de 0 à 4 ans en
France seraient immigrés ou d'origine
immigré on se a donc décidé ce matin
est-ce que c'est vrai ou pas vrai pas
vraiment Thomas et pourtant on serait
tenté d'y croire pourquoi parce que
cette aff information s'appuie sur des
chiffres très sérieux de l'INC sur une
étude de juin 2022 pour être précis qui
indique par classe d'âge la part de la
population étant immigré enfant
d'immigré ou petit enfant d'immigré
c'est une étude qui avait déjà fait
parler d'elle à sa sortie en 2022 donc
Jordan mardellaa le président du
Rassemblement national s'en était emparé
pour étayer et reprendre à son compte la
théorie du Grand remplacement alors je
vous propose de rentrer dans le détail
le chiffre 40 % on le trouve dans
l'étude mais il inclut aussi la la 3è
génération c'est-à-dire quand un enfant
a un grand-parent qui est né hors de
l'Union Européenne et là on comprend que
ça peut devenir beaucoup plus courant et
que ça puisse concerner 40 % des enfants
français en fait si on enlève cette 3è
génération seul 24,6 % des enfants de 0
à 4 ans ont un ou deux parents immigrés
un mini calcul en math et on conclut que
75 % des petits Français n'ont aucun
parent immigré alors il y a une autre
affirmation qui circule depuis l'an 2000
le nombre d'enfants dont les parents
sont nés en France aurait baissé de 22 %
quand le nombre d'enfants dont les
parents sont nés hors Union Européenne
lui aurait augmenté de 72 % vrai ou faux
là encore cette affirmation s'appuie en
partie sur des chiffres issus d'un
recensement démographique très précis de
l'INC en 2000 près de 630000 enfans son
est de deux parents français contre
491000 à peu près en 2022 donc on
constate qu'il y a une baisse ça c'est
un pl à l'inverse à peu près 66000
petits Français sont nés de deux parents
nés hors de l'Union européenne contre
113000 un peu plus de 113000 à peu près
l'an dernier ça augmente mais on
comprend que c'est pas une augmentation
de plus 72 % comme le chiffre qui
circule et puis regardez les valeurs ne
sont pas du tout les mêmes il faudra
attendre au moins plusieurs dizaines
d'années pour voir éventuellement les
courbes se croiser merci beaucoup audreé
Gérard François Dumont on a on a dit
plusieurs fois ici que le le grand
emplacement était pas forcément étayé
scientifiquement est-ce que la chute de
la natalité le rend
plausible non la réalité si vous voulez
c'est que c'est vrai que en ce qui
concerne les immigrants d'origine des
pays du Sud leur fécondité en France est
supérieure à la moyenne nationale mais
ça c'est un phénomène que l'on constate
partout dans la mesure où dans
l'immigration il y a toute une partie de
l'immigration qui n'est pas en situation
régulière et cette partie de
l'immigration effectivement l'une des
façons même si elle a un désir d'enfant
l'une des façons d'avoir la certitude de
passer d'un statut d'irrégulier à
régulier c'est d'avoir un enfant et
d'ailleurs on le voit très bien si vous
voulez ces immigrés là ont un enfant la
première année où elles sont en France
alors c'est un phénomène qui est
particulièrement visible à Mayotte et en
Guyane c'est un phénomène qu'on connaît
très bien aussi aux États-Unis avec les
Hispaniques c'est un phénomène qu'on a
retrouvé vous savez qu'il y a une très
forte émigration à partir du Venezuela
et notamment vers la Colombie h et ça ça
a été très intéressant parce que en fait
les véézuéliennes qui sont arrivés en
Colombie ont souhaitait tout de suite
avoir un enfant pour être sûr d' de pas
être envoyé au Venezuela donc dans un
premier temps leur fécondité a était
très élevée et puis après la Colombie a
modifier sa réglementation pour leur
assurer qu'elles pourront rester en
Colombie et puis là elles ont abissé
leur fécondité donc vous avez un
phénomène comme ceci qui explique
d'ailleurs que c'est en scène saint on a
la fécondité la plus élevée mais il y a
des facteursm culturel qui joue et par
exemple parmi les départements français
qui ont peu d'immigrés et dont la
fécondité particulièrement élevée par
rapport à la moyenne vous avez la maenne
personne ne n'y penserait à priori mais
voilà vous avez une tradition de
fécondité thème
utilisé par l'extrême droite quit on l'a
vu avec Audra peut-être à Tordre un peu
les chiffres regardez janvier 2022
déplacement d'Éric Zemour il est encore
crédité à l'époque de 14,5 % d'intention
de vote selon les sondages il propose
ceci
dès l'été 2022 pour chaque nouvel enfant
né dans une famille de la France rurale
nous mettrons en place une bourse de
naissance de 10000 € c'est une P comment
vous avez réagi à l'époque bah il y a un
problème de d'égalité enfin qui me
semble complètement pourquoi les c'est
quoi les enfants de de famille rural ce
qui est en fait un mot couvert pour dire
les les vrais Français en fait hein
derrière ça et donc c'est extrêmement
problématique et derrière il y a quand
même une attaque sur un principe
fondamental de notre République qui est
le droit droit du sol euh le droit du
sol qui est le même en fait et que les
parents soient immigré ou qu'il soi
français quand un enfant né en France il
peut acquérir être français euh et ça
c'est important de le rappel euh ça a
toujours le peuple français est un
peuple de mélange euh et que toutes les
vagues d'immigration ont abouti que ça
soit les Polonais les Italiens et tout
tout un siècle du 20e siècle à é un
brassage et ce brassage il va rester là
quand que que que Éric Zemour ou pas le
veuille nous sommes très attaché je
pense l'ensemble du peuple français
j'espère est attaché très fortement à ce
droit du sol Pascal Perino un dernier
mot il nous reste moins d'une minute sur
ce même thème est-ce que l'immigration
musulmane en disons les mots change
cette cette logique écoutez tout dépend
des terrains on voit bien comment tout à
l'heure on citait en effet laass saint
là on a un terrain sur lequel on a plus
que l'impression que la dynamique
démographique est portée par une
population immigrée ou issu de
l'immigration hein euh et c'est
certainement un des facteurs euh qui
participe de ces tension que l'on voit
dans la société française puisque deux
Français sur trois disent aujourd'hui il
y a trop d'immigrés en France c'est un
des éléments euh qui participe de cette
tension dans la mesure où sur certains
terrain les Français peuvent avoir
l'impression qu'il n'y a qu'il y a une
forme d'anémie démographique de la
population des Français avec des multip
dit de souche hein issu de l'immigration
polonaise italienne et cetera euh et des
Français plus récent ou des étrangers
sur le territoire national he c'est un
des éléments qui doit permettre tout
même de comprendre que l'enjeu
immigration en France faut pas l'enjeu
immigration reste un des enjeux qui est
privilégié parmi les trois enjeux les
plus importants à quelques mois des
élections européennes il ne faut pas
oublier cette composante évidemment
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à à ce débat je vais rappeler
Gérard françin Dumont le la revue
Population et Avenir le dernier numéro
on va le revoir qui s'intitule politique
familiale et vitalité démographique
merci encore à bientôt sur sur Public
Sénat